welcome to this comprehensive video
course on MIM cached an inmemory caching
system known for its Simplicity and
Effectiveness in reducing database load
in this course Hussein will teach you
about MC's architecture and design
choices and he'll conclude with a
Hands-On demo using Docker and telnet
get ready to deepen your understanding
of this transient cache system mimc D is
a simple inmemory key e Value Store
written in c h it was originally I think
written in Pearl and then Rewritten in C
this is what back in 2003 so it's been a
while and it has been popular with
companies such as Facebook Netflix
Wikipedia Facebook I think pushed it to
its limit you know and the most uh and
the reason it's why popular is because
of its Simplicity and we're going to
talk about that I know we throw the word
simple a lot these days but MIM casd is
truly simple I
mean if you're looking for advanced
features it's not here it was designed
to be simple solve the problems of the
web back in 2003 which is we want to
help alleviate the queries to the
database we're we're you know the
databases are taking a hit you know so
let's cash things although I usually do
not agree with having a cash to solve a
slow query because I think personally I
think it's a cop out you know to to just
add a cash when you have a slow query
you have to understand why it's slow you
have to understand why it exactly taking
time why there are a lot of logic reads
and how to minimize it and that's
another story for another day but
sometimes you need a cash of course
right and then MIM casd was born right
of course there are alternatives such as
redus I made a video about it but this
this video is to is a crash course of
mhd we're going to dive into the agenda
here you're watching this on YouTube
there will be uh chapters where you can
jump into the interesting part of the
things but it's an inmemory database
we're going to talk about memory
management you might say why well we're
going to find out memory management is
not easy at all you know it's not just
like hey just throw things in memory and
then read it it's a little bit more
complicated than that going talk about
the Ario the least recently used uh
which was designed to
avoid growing the memory of this
instance unlimitedly right CU you have
to have a some sort of a a mechanism to
evi all entries that has been never used
that's why you cannot really rely on MIM
cash D to have a value always there it
was never the goal of this cash right
unlike Reddit right is if you if you
store something is going to be there and
you told it to be there forever it's
going to stay forever it will make sure
to stay forever MIM casd does not
guarantee that and you can argue that
this is actually a feature and you can
argue that this is something you don't
want you know
so tread
lightly thread we're going to talk about
the threading model cuz you have to have
multiple threads if you want to serve a
lot a lot a lot of clients with a lot a
lot a lot of TCP connection connected to
this thing read and WR we're going to go
through examples of a read example for
the write and okay kind of uh open the
hood and look what is inside this
beautiful
thing locking model obviously uh two
people trying to write in the same item
it's not as advanced as acid obviously
where you have isolation levels now it's
a serialized model where we try not to
have two people read the thing item at
the same time or write uh the same item
at the same time so locking and we're
going to talk about the old model and
the new model that's where you really
try to understand what how things are
built is completely different from the
way we explain it distributed cach I
know they say it's a distributed cach
but I kind of don't like to say that
because in itself MIM casd is not
distributed it's just when you spin up a
m casd instance three M casd instance
they don't know about each other and
they will never be right the client is
responsible for the distribution so I
kind of reluctant to say it's a
distributed cash I know people call it a
distributed cach I don't like to do that
but hey it is a distributed cache if you
if you if you put the distribution at
the client side and I think this is part
of the beautiful simple design they
they on purpose they didn't make it
distributed to make it simple and then
we're going to go through a demo we're
going to use Docker because you can spin
up a lot of instances in in Docker
really easily let's do that so in memory
key value St what's that really uh we're
going to talk about some terminology
here specific to mkd an item that's what
they call it an item is really what
consist of a key and a value a key is
usually should be unique right and a
value could be literally anything a key
has to be a string and it maxed out at
250 character you can see the limits
right that's why I think uh redis kind
of won the cash game when it comes to
this thing because MIM Cas has a lot of
limits and uh this kind of uh you know
crippled some people from using this
cache because of these limits right but
you can Ario also the Simplicity of this
design and if you can work around the
the design to use MIM
casd it it's actually pretty nice right
when when they key as a strength they
did that for a Simplicity reason to
right if if you support like dates uh or
or I don't know like blobs as Keys then
Things become really complicated and
there shows in the architecture and if
there is a bug it's really hard to track
down right and the value can be any type
h it's by default one megabyte again
another limitation in MIM casd yeah you
can see that I I talk about limitation
but these limitations technically to me
I I see them as features you know
because they didn't claim to be like the
best in the world they said hey we are
designed to be simple and I appreciate
and I completely love that you know when
you say I want to build something simple
the simple thing has limitations right
the simple thing will by Design have
limitation when you look at the big
picture right it's not going to have
like tons of features right so yeah you
can configure this to to increase it but
again it's not really a good idea all
the time uh Keys have exploration date
ttls right time to Liv and uh even that
don't rely on that right even if you put
like a key that has like a 1 hour and
your memory is filled the lru will can
kick in and if you never use that key
it's going to get affected and they tell
you that right hey mkd is a transad
we're not going to make sure that it's
actually persisted it's not supposed to
be that
right again always go back to the the
requirements here they never meant right
for this to be a persisted cash forever
right you don't rely on that you kind of
use it to help you avoid expensive
queries but yeah be ready at any time
that this value is not going to be there
everything is stored in memory right
that's why it done cash MIM Cas D again
don't confuse MIM Cas D with MIM Cas DB
that's a completely different project
and I think it's abandoned since 2019
2009 right but yeah m casd is still
going and Facebook and I think Mark
Zucker give a presentation about M casd
as well at some point how they tuned it
to its maximal values let's talk about
memory management here's the memory
right when you allocate items you know
when you say hey I want to allocate an
array and iate an integer and I want
tocate a here's a block of M you know
these items that you allocate and even
you new program today they going to go
in random places now they yes the
process has a dedicated memory area but
when you allocate these things go random
so the grain is allocated they're going
to go to random places right yeah
initially they might be consequent but
as you uh remove and free items you're
going to end up with these gaps so you
might say what's wrong with these gaps
the problem is like this this is called
the fragmentation what's wrong with
fragmentation well you're going to have
like a little bit of few bytes here few
bytes here few bytes here few here but
if you want like a big bulk of memory
location consent like you want one Meg
you have one Meg but it's fragmented and
guess what if it's fragmented you cannot
use it you cannot just allocate here oh
my part and then part here and this part
here I think that the operating system
allows you to do that maybe but then it
will it will crash left and right to
collect what you have right we had the
same problem with hard drive I guess
right back in the days with
fragmentation where the the seek you
know the the needle has to to go
multiple places to fit your files
because it's a circle right this this
desk and has the if if you store a file
and you start editing the file the files
will go to multiple sectors and to read
that file back you have to go sector one
sector two
this was supposed to be like a rotating
disc I failed miserably but you get
point right so memory fragmentation is
bad we try to avoid it right new items
can can no longer fit so what what did
they do so me casd at least what they
did is they allocate pages instead even
if they don't use it they say hey when
you
start I look at the whole page one Meg
again that's that's the design right
that that's the reason why we have one
value up to one megabyte you cannot go
beyond that so they say hey let's start
with one Meg so if they allocate they
allocate at one Meg the whole thing they
don't use it technically to the
operating system you the cash has used 1
Megabyte it doesn't know it right that
it's not actively using it that client
us connecting to M casd we're not
probably we're using like part of that
memory does that make sense but this
avoids frag M mentation right cuzz now
all of this just one big page with a lot
of empty space right but it is
elated and then there is this idea of
chunks right so the pages are broken
down into equal size of they call chunk
so um keep these in mind the terminology
in mind the chunk is a fix size and what
determines the chunk size is actually
something called a slab class right and
the slab is think of a slab every time I
hear the word slab I remember Dark Souls
you know it's a video game where you
have the last item that you require in
order to upgrade your weapon it's called
a titanite slab where it's say like
really large rock that you use in order
to upgrade your weapon it's a it's it's
basically a a a big thing a slab of meat
they say right it's just a big thing
that's what it means so this idea of
slab and slab classes will always show
up up here so it's like a b big portion
of memory a slab class is what define
the chunk size right so there is there
will be a slab class of 40 bytes there
will be a slab class of a one Meg so the
chunk sizes will be 44 bytes right and
the chunk sizes for a slab class of that
type is one Meg so we're going to show
an example to cons to to show that of
stuff and the pages consist of fixed
chunk size right items are in chunks
here's the a very important item so your
item will be stored in the chunk your
chunk size could be let's say uh 100 BYT
right if it's 100 BYT and your item
which includes the key and the value is
less than 100 you're going to include
the whole chunk right so if it's 90 byte
you lost 10 byte within that chunk
nothing to do about it sorry right
that's one limitation here so there
there will be a free space a tiny free
space in the chunk chunk and obviously
each slab class has a fixed chunk size
so that's how they are determined it's
going to be clear as we go through them
obviously avoid memory fragmentation
here's an example right so here we have
a slab class with a chunk size of 72 at
subass one and slab class 43 for example
the chunk size is one Meg so you have in
a single page right so slap class have
multiple pages and sometimes they call
them also the is called slabs the word
slab in the documentation is so
overloaded and I've seen people use it
one over the other so I avoid using it
the word slap so a slap class and there
are pages right so this page in this
case we said one Meg right and the
chunks are 72 divided that means we have
one
14563 chunks per page but each chunk is
72 byte right so if you have an item
around 72 byte fits nicely in this right
but if your item is larger let's say
900k then oh it doesn't fit this slab
class so we need to let's let's find out
what is the subass for this item oh
subass 42 because the closest one Mig
and guess what the
one the one Mig
class slab class has this entire page is
one chunk right so this is really
important to understand here right so
that's how they allocate memories this
we're looking at the internal
architecture of M casd here right let's
go example new item 40 byte 40 byte the
closest thing is this guy right slab
class one let's allocate memory and then
Boop no we don't allocate memory that
this memory is already allocated right
we just store the item right in this
chunk and then we start adding pointers
and stuff stuff like that here so now
our item is right here we're going to
talk about the hash table and stuff like
that but this is just again memory
management let's say I have a new item
900k oh this fits right here so one big
chunk in one page right so that's
interesting let's say another new item
40 byte but guess what slab slab class
one because that's the what the chunk
size is fits it nicely but guess what we
have two pages they're all completely
full so I cannot insert this what do we
do create a brand new page put that
thing here does that make sense so we
allocate the new page and when you go to
the demo we're going to see all this
stuff right we're going to do a stats
and see like oh how number of pages
allocated is this right so it's just I I
absolutely love how they did this it's
interesting obviously doesn't doesn't
have limitation of course but you're
going to see that depends on the sizes
of the item you say and once you really
understand how things work you you can
architect your application specifically
the back end here frontend doesn't
really talk to M casd at all right the
back end here can be architected so that
you can choose the perfect items right
to fit this entire thing right you're
not going to just choose hophazardly
right that's how you know your craft
effectively all right let's get to the
meat lru least recently used you know
the main problem with memory is it's
limited you know and even if MIM casd
allocated certain amount of memory if
you store a lot a lot a lot of keys even
with good expiration date memory can get
full what do you do do you
block new
inserts I would say that's that's one
feature that you can add I suppose
but but mimk they don't allow you to do
it they won't let you go to that state
you if the memory is be about to be full
then anything that hasn't been used for
a very long time they will release it
that's another reason where REM Cas D is
a transient memory it do not rely on a
key even if you said the expire for an
hour do not rely to that key to be to be
there in an hour it can go any any time
right that's another limitation that's
another feature right I say limitation
and a feature at the same time because
it is it is a feature right and it's to
some people it's a limitation and how do
they do that right they use something
called the link List have you ever heard
about this before and 20 years ago 21
years ago uh in the University I took a
course and the Cs CS 101 they talked
about link list and that is pretty much
the the only time in my entire
professional career I ever used a link
list that's probably I'm not saying
that's just the case with my the
application I wrote is all high level
languages I never had to write a
database or a m cache you know so I
never used the link list right so
doesn't doesn't mean that it's it's a
useless structure but it is it's a
important data structure why cu the
least recently used is a link list
there's a head and there's a tail and
every item is linked to each other so if
all these items that you add are the in
this architecture right they are in the
link class and there is every slap class
has its own lru right so if I for
example access an item that happens to
be in the tail it will be popped and go
back to the head so there is a cost to
accessing an item there is a cost there
is a cost of removing this chain put it
that back pull the head to this pull
this guy to this guy pull this guy to
this guy that's how you do linkless
right so every time you access an item
it goes back to the head so items that
are not used they will automatically be
pushed down to the tail and if the
memory is Out Of Reach basically these
items will be removed from the tail but
also another thing with with this link
list is like with threads if you with
which MD is is multi-threaded app how
can you have multiple threads read at
the same items right you can't you have
to lock this structure you know if
people who done multi-threading you have
to you have to lock it right and the
moment you do locking if you if you know
about something about databases which I
a course on database engineering check
out check it out it's actually right
here database. husin as.com I talk about
all this stuff you know in details in
fundamental details you know so don't
expect like SQL syntaxes in my courses
not like that I talk about fundamentals
which which should then build up and see
how the client is built out right but
yeah locks is a very critical concept
here you have to lock it to avoid this
you know mutation you know corruption
right but yeah it's a cost and there's
an a you CLW crawler and a demon that
does the cash inection from the tail
right and again every time it kicks out
have to lock and then if it's locked
people cannot read people threads cannot
read and if threads cannot read latency
right block
slow right all of this you got to
understand when things happen this is
why and I'm going to share my opinion
about the lru right and I think this is
a good time by the way there is an L
cache per slab class I think I mentioned
that so the one Meg slab class right
which has like pages of one Meg and the
chunk sizes of one Meg has its own laru
and each other sub slab class has its
own L by the way I don't make I'm not
making any of this up I'm I had to read
frankly maybe 20 different documents to
collect this information and and kind of
present it in a summarized manner here
right because there is no one dog to
explain all that unfortunately right
it's it's not incomplete unfortunately
that's what I noticed and
outdated so my opinion about the lru in
my in my personal humble opinion is I
wish MIM casd actually disa this by
default you know L is a feature right
and they the reason they added it
because memory is limited especially
back in 2003 when they first built this
thing memory was so scarce or scarce is
it scarce or scarce scarce right it's
very limited and when you do that you
don't want to run out of memory right so
if you allocate certain amount of memory
for M casd it can easily run out right
if you have a lot of keys so how do you
manage that they say hey we're going to
remove we're going to build an
laru least recently items K get kicked
out from my memory that's a fine but I
wish they disabled that by default or
give us an option to disable it because
the overhead of managing AIO and you can
see from the papers I'm going to
reference is so large the locks that
they have to maintain slows down
throughput right and comp and complicate
the application so I think they stuck
whoever built this 20 in 2003 MIM casd
Brad Fitzpatrick who is the original
developer of MIM casd he built this for
his website live Journal you know I wish
he disabled this by default I really
wish because his original design is so
simple and so elegant I absolutely love
it you know you build something so
simple with its featur stripped there
are no much features
U made it not simple unfortunately yeah
cool have this a feature but disabled by
by
default or have an option to disable I
don't know if there's an option to
disable maybe there is but hey I want to
take the responsibility as a client
right if I'm going to allocate certain
amount of memory cuz I'm responsible I'm
going to give uh MIM cash D 5 gig 10 gig
and my application is smart enough to
know to set expiry date right for this
item and yeah if I'm going to get errors
if it's failed out it's on me I want to
delete an items I want to do this
management this
way for 95% of the users who want simple
things they're going to get it l are you
in my personal opinion again this is
just my personal opinion you can agree
or disagree I think you should this this
should have been disabled because now
they they created a new lru which is
like has hot and warm and cold and and
they move stuff around because they have
a lot of problems with lru like moving
stuff around all the time is so
expensive you know so it it has a cost
so let us just how about eh give me an
option not to use it and go back to a
simple model of course I I don't I don't
mind if two items two users trying to
access the same two threads trying to
access the same item at the same time
let them be serialized that's fine right
but lru as a whole thing I think it's a
it's just to me over engineering that's
just my opinion you can disagree here is
how it looks like by the way aot you in
the big picture again this is all
drawings I made it uh I could be wrong
in small details because I don't I don't
know the actual architecture so this is
I derive this from reading the source
code and the doc so this is how it looks
like so this is this is where we talk
about the pages right and the chunks so
the chunks or the items is what being
lru right so the head is right here and
this is linked to this item this is link
to this item this link to this item this
this is the tail so this is how it looks
like every item here is actually linked
to the next to the one next to it right
this is think this of this as a snapshot
after many many usages right gets and
red that so so things will move to the
head and the tail obviously I didn't
draw every particular thing because it's
going to be a mess of a drawing but you
get the point right that's that that's
how the L you and you can see how
complex things get so let's talk about
threading so this is one of my favorite
Parts I know uh I absolutely have um I
absolutely love networking and if you're
interested I have a networking course
and and this part is is all about
sockets connections the way listeners
work the way the TCP connection works I
talk this about this in detail in my
network course if you're interested go
to network. hus n.com learn more about
that again network.has nasa.com this URL
redirected immediately to UD me with the
latest coupon applied so uh you're going
to get a discount and you're going to be
supporting this channel this work thank
you so much there's here's the threading
model for uh for mam casd right because
it accepts clients it has to have
networking right so what they do is they
listen on a TCP Port right so that means
they support transmission control
protocol that's the native transport
that they support they also support UDP
which I didn't mention here but UDP has
been now disabled by default because of
an attack that happened 4 years ago 2018
uh reflection attack actually right with
with MIM casd public servers so it was
the cloud flare actually reported that
so UDP has been disabled by default but
yeah you can use it if you want but yeah
let's stick with TCP right now TCP Port
11211 and there is a listener thread so
one spin up listener one thread that
spins up it listen to Port 11211 so that
creates a socket right in the operating
system speak right and that basically
creates its own accept Q it's on syn Q
this is how the application start
accepting connection right so
everything every single connection that
is happening The Listener thread will
accept it so there is a loop infinite
Loop here literally all application has
this Loop where it's constantly
accepting uh connections one thread
right so all the connections goes to
this thread so once it accept the
connection it gets the file descriptor
we call it right which actually
represents the connection and now what
what mimk does is spins up a new thread
gives that file descriptor to that
thread now if a stream of data if a
request to get a
key was sent to this connection it will
the operating system knows to send it to
this thread well technically what
happens is the thread pulls the
descriptor right this is now this thre
is responsible for this connection This
Thread is responsible for this
connection This Thread is responsible
for this connection so you can see
that now this model just blows up right
if a one connection PA of thread if you
have so many connections you can R run
out of threads right or that kind also
blows your memory and CPU so be careful
with that as well I think they put a
limit number of connections M casd I
might be wrong there but yeah so this is
basically explains all of that now the
moment you have threading now the beauty
here is you don't have bottleneck right
if you have one thread that is
responsible for all the connections and
listening you you will be blocked right
one user will send a key and then
another user will send a key they won't
be served right they have to be
serialized because there's one thread
actually executing them one by one right
but here if one user executes a sends a
key request to get a key and this guy
want to write they can happen at the
same time right this thread will read it
and this thread will read it they are
different processing this could be in a
core this could be in a completely
different core that could be also
possible versus it's one thread then
becomes really a a problem so we had to
go with multi- threads what's the
problem with that well the problem is
these threads will try to access what we
call the laru and the items and the
memory so everything is shared between
all these threads but you can't have two
threads right to the same location
that's a problem that's why the original
design had one Global lock it was
serialized so in this case yeah the
threads kind of helped with the
connection but but you were serialized
at the Locking model so nobody can even
access two different items has nothing
to do with each other they were serious
they were locked so one thread has to be
served after the other they they fixed
that they completely red that now it's a
pair item log so if two threads try to
access the same item then there will be
SSE that's good that's okay I'm okay
with that right but yeah if I am
accessing item one key number one and
then another thre access key number two
at the same time they should be served
at the same time what there is no reason
for locking and the only reason we lock
is because we want to update the lru
again so there is so much stuff that
comes back always to the lru it's like
oh really we did we really need an lru
why what if we disabled by default right
okay that's just me let's go through an
example read and this is something we
never talked about here which is the
hash table if you think about it if you
have a key how do you actually find
where this key lives right if you think
about it you need hash tables so what
you do and I talked about hash table in
my YouTube channel uh look up hashing
and consistent hashing I talk about
details hash table is nothing but an
associative array it's really just an
array and the beauty of an array is if
you have an array right let's talk about
arrays a little bit if you have an array
from an array has to be consecutive if
you allocate an array of a thousand
elements accessing element number seven
access an element number
10243 is biger of one is fast because
you know the index once you know the
index and you know the head of the array
you add the address to the index voila
you have the address and the memory of
the CPU can immediately go to that
location that's the beauty you have an
index with hash tables you don't have an
index you have a key the trick is to
convert the key back to an index that is
all what it is a hash table nothing
fancy it's just an array so we take that
what we do is the do a hash on the key
right let's say I'm going to R test key
right and then do a hash and then do
modul n where n is the size of this
array or the hash table right and then
you're going to get a value between zero
and N minus one I guess right so now
okay let's go point it and that's big of
one plus the cast of The Hash right now
you got here found it now what you do is
you're going to get a pointer which
takes you to the the page on that
specific slab class for that item which
is happened to be D in this case that's
how a read works so it's a big off one
you can argue that this is one read and
this is a second read yeah I suppose
that works too right I think the the new
model have kind of two hash tables if
I'm mistaken but I couldn't find detail
docs about this so I explain this so I
apologies if this is a little bit out of
date but this gives you the idea here
the new two hashes I think uh they were
provided to provide a pair item lock and
obviously what happened here is this is
the lru you access the item the D is
pushed to the head right so now you have
a b c d a is now the least recently used
item is in the tail and a points to b b
points to C C points to D and obviously
it's a revers length as well so D point
to c c points to B P point to a right so
that's how they allot you actually what
you if you think about it the the
pointers are right here in the item
itself right but I drew it this way for
Simplicity otherwise it's not readable
at all read two this is another example
for read I'm going to read Buzz hash the
buzz get the N whoa get the item Boop
get a c nice now when we get a c the C
is pushed to the Head D is slightly
pushed and then obviously the allario is
updated and that's another lock right
you have to do a lock to do that so if
buzz and whatever the value before a
test was read at the same time they are
serialized at the lru level if they
belong to the same slab class again this
might have change with the new
architecture they changed that a little
bit so I think that you can you can play
with that a little bit but again to
update the L you have to you have to
kind of acquire a lock so you're going
to be serialized right here yeah
let's go through a write I'm going to
write key new of a value with
44 whopping bites let's do that well to
write we need to obviously find the hash
right where to write it hash module in
get that puppy find where to write it oh
happen to be an empty location sure
that's good right and now you have
questions what if what if I happen to
have something that is already written
you can you can have collisions and
we're going to talk about collisions in
a minute right it's a problem of hash
tables hash tables are fun and good but
the moment they you run into collisions
and you want to resize it it falls apart
but now I create a new pointer this
pointer now I need to allocate a slab
class not slab class I need to allocate
a a chunk where going to put my item in
and that chunk goes into a specific slab
class well 44 bytes pick a a slab class
right and even the slab classes guys by
the way it's not really fixed you can
play with those the other configuration
called the Chun the chunk Factor growth
size I'm not going to mention it here
it's just going to make the course a
little bit longer but you you get the
point there are so many tweaking you can
play with right tweak these chunk sizes
but yeah I look at a new memory location
in this specific page in an empty page
in a fit a fitting chunk right because
you want to pick a chunk that is almost
fits right in the chunk right not too
small obviously cannot be larger than
the chunk SI I have to fit right into it
right but then that's the the that's
what the what MIM casy does all right
let's spice things up let's say I'm
going to write a key called Nanny which
is a new key I don't have it before and
value 44 but it happened to clash with
another existing key because that's
hashes always do that right so when you
do that you hash Nan and happen to be
fitting on a entry that already have a
pointer what do we do do we overwrite it
no what they did is this is called a
bucket by the way right they add more
item to the bucket you know we have one
item let's call it I don't know test or
something all right and then we have
Nani which fits right in the same bucket
what we do is just we make it into a
chain this chain of buckets right
actually one bucket with two items I
don't know right whatever the
terminology doesn't really matter you
just read to understand let's turn back
the laser here and yeah we're going to
add it here and then just do the pointer
and do the do your thing now obviously
we need to talk about a collision what
happen to Collision I want to read the
keani right go here hash it obviously go
here oh we have two which one
Ah that's the cost you have to go one by
one through all of them right why
because now we have a hash you don't
know one of which one of these are
actually Nanny what you do is read the
first one right check it compare the key
oh because if you go to the item you're
going to find the actual key right
that's stored here so you're going to
find it and say oh that's not 90 that's
something else right let's go through
the bucket go to the next one there you
go that's my item
so here is a completely different paper
that you can write here this P people
take phds in this stuff by the way guys
you know this is called the the the
scale factor you know mimc D measures
this growth and if it's too much based
on a certain percentage if you're
overloading then then you're going to
still see performance problems right
reading a key is going to have to go
through multiple reads to find the
actual key versus if it goes right here
hey the key is right here of course
there's one entry it has to be it right
but if there's
multiple yeah then it's a problem right
I mean you can you can think about it
you can argue that you can hash a key
that happened to get to a value that is
not there so technically you have to
read it and compare because your key
might not exist but it happened to Hash
to a value that does right so you have
to read it so there is a cost to reading
so that's the problem of hash table so
and if that's the case then they do a
hash
resize and boy when you rehash your
table they have to shift everything
around and I believe this is when they
use the consisting hashing which is this
ring concept which I talked about in
another video and that just gets really
complicated right because they know now
the moment you resized your hash table
you need to move stuff around because
Nanny will not be this index number one
anymore it going to be index number 7700
something like that right 1700 is not a
number I think I'm going to skip this
because we talked about locking in a
minute we talk about thre threads and
then accessing the lru and how it was a
global lock and then it changed to a
pair item lock and then still we have
ref counting you know every time you
read an item you increase the ref count
you know and when you release it you
decrement the rount this is for so the
garbage collection can the garbage
collection is written in C there's no
garbage collector but the the the the
ephemeral application Level garbage
collection when Elio kick in can remove
the item because you cannot just remove
the item if if someone is referencing it
that's the definition of meem memory
leaks right all right let's talk about
distributed cach and how it's uh MIM
casd is actually not a distributed cash
in my opinion mimc D servers when you
spin up a mimc d server mcash D server
they are completely isolated you cannot
link a server to another server there is
no mechanism to do that right when you
spin up a mimc d server it's a mimc d
server it doesn't talk to another
servers and I absolutely love this
design how simple and elegant this is
put the responsibility if you want to do
distributed well the apis at the client
side has to do that and that's what
we're going to show in the in the code
section where we're going to write our
own uh we're going to use a nodejs
application to do that of course we're
going to use also tnet to connect to
that and write stuff right but we're
going to go through all this stuff now
but yeah what happens here is the client
actually knows about all the servers it
has knowledge so the client site
actually does the distribution right so
it's like okay key number one go here
key number two go here key number three
go here so there's a hashing going on
consistent hashing to be specific you
can build your own mimc D client that
does whatever you want right and then
distribute that stuff well what happen
if I if I add a if I add a server well
your client can start Distributing the
keys I would
definitely not be with that that because
why would you distribute the keys for in
a transient cash anyway who cares at a
server is like oh yeah if if the kid is
not there you're going to query the
database and pull it up right it's it's
not worth it to do this this chattiness
to move items around from one server to
another that's just a bad idea I don't
know if clients do it maybe they do but
I don't think it's it's required it's
just thrashing for the case thrashing D
B Shing
again you you might if you know this
channel you know that I'm I try as much
as possible to push it as the last
resort I do not like distributed
stuff especially so complex to deal with
right I like Simplicity I'm a simple
man right but yeah sometimes you
go you have you go to the YouTube scale
and Google scale then you don't have a
choice one machine cannot possibly
handle everything I would I would go
with raid replicas I would go with
partitioning horizontal
partitioning in the server itself
minimize that as much as possible I
would go with raid you know distributed
dis storage but the application remain
as a single writer the moment you have
multiple writers and you have to deal
with the Shing it becomes really complex
you know if you want to deal with the
complex complexity sure but yeah that's
that's the idea of distributed
cash okay let's do a demo we're going to
do a demo we're going to spin up a bunch
of MIM cash D Docker instances so for
this exercise just install Docker and
you're good to go and you have to have a
Docker H you have to have a Docker
account because somehow they are locked
behind an account M casd I have no idea
why did that they did do they do that
sometimes right so you just just create
an account do a Docker login you're good
to go right once you do that you can
download the image and you can spin up
as many MIM cash G instances as you want
so we're going to do that I'm going to
use tnet because I love the Simplicity
of MIM casd you know how many clients
these days that you can actually just
til it and run commments to they can be
counted on one finger you know they
don't exist anymore the Simplicity is
gone from
these from today's applications right
the good old days of you just telling it
and run and one thing I didn't mention
is M casd doesn't have security by
default so that might be a deal breaker
for you right so you have to you can
Implement authentication which doesn't
exist by default sassel I believe they
call it you can Implement TLS if you
want but by defa they don't have any of
that stuff right so take it with a grain
of salt right they they said simple it
is simple right but you have to be
careful in a cloud environment when it
comes to MIM casd you have to TLS it
right they support that there is a
support for that and obviously we're
going to use no JSM Cas D for this
consistent hashing and we going to put
all our Docker containers and and play
with that a little bit how about we do
that so I have Docker installed here on
my Mac you can have Windows and install
Docker on top of it you can have Linux
install Docker on top of it that's why I
always like to use Docker just it's an
agnostic whether whe whatever your
application is you know whatever your
operating system Docker works you know
we have it on top of all all of this
stuff so let's go ahead and spin up a
Docker container that have a mimc d
instance one MIM casd instance right so
Docker run you do das Das name let's
give it a name uh let's called it M1 M
casd or M1 right you don't have to give
it a name but I like that so that we can
find it and delete it later
easily and then you can expose the port
uh by default
11211 right
11211 so this is what is running in the
container this is what is exposed in my
host right cuz I'm going to hit my host
which is Hussein Mac which is that's the
actual host that is running Docker and
then I'm going to hit that Port which
will be Port forwarded to this Con
container and I'm going to spin up
another one with 11 211 11 212 and 1121
three right later we're going to spin up
multiple ones and then finally we're
going to do MIM cache d right if you do
just like that this will block the uh
the terminal you know and it's going to
be just work so I I suggest you do that
first I know it's going to work for me
because I I did it before but I like to
do dashd right- d means just hey detach
it because I'm going to use this
terminal for something else later right
so just go just like that we created a
container it can do Docker PS to make
sure that the container is running
obviously if the image is not there it's
going to download it for you and you
have to do Docker login to do all that
stuff so do all of that log to your
account and uh all that stuff all right
so let's test it
out how do you test it tell it what are
we telling it into Hussein Mac which is
my host and which Port 11211 again this
is the port that I exposed that happen
to be the same doesn't have to right if
I do that all of a sudden I'm logged in
how do I do that well let's do a stats
give me your stats and this is the stuff
that most of the stuff here we talked
about currently right up time what's the
version of MCD the pointer size maximum
number of connections 1024 we talked
about that right there's a maximum
number of connections uh how many times
you run a get how many times you run a
set how many times you
incremented uh the threads how many
threads you have here right eviction how
many times they allow you kicked in and
evicted stuff and then you can do like
stats uh Slack I think which going to
give you like how many slabs were active
how many is actually allocated obviously
we don't have anything because we didn't
do anything right so let's go ahead and
set something so to set a key you do set
and then you do the key let's call it Fu
and then um the flags zero I don't have
any Flags here Flags you can do further
controls over here and the second
parameter here is the expiration so
let's say it's 3,600 which is an hour
right you can set it for for an hour you
can say it for a minute you can say it
for a second if you want right that's
the expiration so if your item ever get
to after an hour it will be Eed it will
not be returned to you not necessarily
will be Eed until the lru kicks in and
that actually physically removes it
right and then finally we're going to uh
put the data length how how how big is
the value that you're going to set let's
say two characters here right so I'm
going to do high you have to exactly
match it right otherwise it's going to
be uh it's not going to fit nicely right
so now we sto the value so let's read
that value give yay I know this is just
very simple stuff but you get the point
right you can you can uh increment you
can you can delete that key right and if
you delete it you can read that it's not
there so very simple stuff I don't
really care about the API more I want
more to talk about the architecture of
stuff here right and that's what matters
here there's there are actually two
protocols command set this is the old
one and there's the new one which is
starts with mg like two characters and
there's like a different set of syntax
right there are two syntaxes here syntax
can you say syntaxes I I guess you do
you can but you can play with this it's
very simple you connect to that and you
see I didn't log in there's no accounts
or anything like that there's no
collection that you create it's just a
free floating right some people might
like that some people might not like
that cuz they want partitioning hey let
me create a table or collection let me
play with that key value right there so
it's a it's a freefor all if I if I
destroy this connection so if I destroy
it and I connect it again right and I do
get F obviously it's not there because
we deleted it so if I set it again um
black zero let's said it for 10 seconds
or or 2000 seconds
whatever and then to high stored get Fu
right if I killed it now let's kill the
session right quit and then do again
connect and then get Fu the value is
still there obviously right cuz it's
it's stort in memory right even if I
connect it as a different TCP connection
right and now that we did that if you do
stats slabs you can see some interesting
values that we talked about here right
let's chunk size right so we have this
number one which is this represent the
slab class that we talked about right so
we happen to have one slab class because
my value is so tiny right if I created
another chunk with a large value the
large item another slap class will be
created and that will have its own
configuration so the chunks per page
which we talked about
10,922 we have one page only as we add
items we can just increase that if we
want how many is in used one chunk how
many is free 21 109 21 so that's the
total we used one how many time we read
it how many time we said it how many
time we delet it everything here is
actually uh accounted for active slabs
we have one slab right here effectively
active and this is the memory allocated
right so it's like
what that's like uh one Meg exactly
right that's the make is that is
allocated we talked about
that so yeah so you can start playing
with that and add M multiple data points
and and look at the stats and play with
it a little bit so let's
control this and quit so now that we
talked about tillet how about we
actually go to nodejs and build our
beautiful interesting application here
all right so I created this I went to my
project folder here I'm going to go Ahad
and create a directly called no mod M
right and I just go ahead and do that
right do an mpm init Dy right I have
nodejs of of course installed right here
to do all this stuff right and then um
let's create an index.js file and we're
going to do const MIM cached equal I
believe it just do require MIM cache
literally and that's the library we're
going to install so
once we have this Library we can call it
right how can I call it const um let
call it server and then we're going to
create a new MIM cached and here's the
interesting thing you can pass in an
array of servers and you can pass in a
string you can pass in an array or you
can pass an object if you pass an array
then the uh the the keys will be evenly
distributed between all these instances
today I have only one server so Hussein
Mac
11211 all right close the array we're
going to add more servers later but
that's that's it basically because
server I guess server pool is a better
name huh let's let's call it server pool
because that's what it is it's a server
pool here let's create a function called
run and this function will be called in
right and this function we're going to
use the server pool and we're going to
set a value so here's how we set a value
set pool uh server pool do set and you
give it a key say F right and then the
value bar right and then expiration day
an hour and then the final one is a call
back which gives you like in case of an
error I'm not going to set it because I
trust that it's going to just work so
all we have to do is
uh do that and this will just set the
value but for the sake of time I'm going
to actually set 10 values 3 4 5 6 S 8
nine for those who know JavaScript we
can do this trick like for each I I
think you can do a better job at this
than I will but I think this works right
this this should work
right I like that that so they will have
a different
key a and the bar will have a this way
we'll set what 10 values in this case
and each value will have the full a for
one and bar one for two bar two the
reason I do this is because I want to
actually see the I'm not going to read
it from here all of us going to do that
is just run and I'm going to read it
from tnet right that's how I'm going to
do it let's go ahead and do save mpm
install MIM
casd and then
npm that's it node index. GS hopefully
it
runs and of course the moment I say that
I have an error so let's go ahead and
and check the error here so I going to
see what the error is for
each so let's go ahead and just add that
okay this is going to print the error in
case there is an error just in case all
right try it
again node index
toj all right now works I had like a
typo so I had effect but look at this
get full three get full four get full
five we're getting all the values that
is pretty cool you guys right it's
pretty cool so here's what I'm going to
do now let's control exit here quit
here's what I'm going to do now I'm
going to spin up
more containers so it's going to do run
Das Dash name MIM 2 right they call it-
p1212 2
11211 again this is the actual Port will
this will not change this is what's
changing here right right here right
detach MIM cash d right got to do the
same thing or
three
three that is pretty neat right and uh
for for sake of completing let's add so
four servers why servers are free we can
we can spin up as much as we want now
let's edit our application right here
and uh what we're going to do
is literally just add a comma say hey
hin Mac 11212 is another server right
there's another one too hin Mac all they
are living in the same server if you
think about it right it's just different
Services right J say mac 11214
that is awesome nothing changes right so
I'm going to do it again and then node
index.js I don't want you to pay
attention to what will happen now The
Client app now distributed all the stuff
to all the servers so now my foods will
be all over the place Let's test it out
tet Hussein Mac uh
11212 right let's connect to
11212 the second server and then get f
one it's right there get F two not there
get F three not yeah it's right there
good F four it's not there get it
because now the distribution is up to
the cine I have no idea how how this
will be distributed probably round robin
but uh could be something else right so
if I pick now another server right three
let's do that get f one not there get F
two not there get F three not there good
full four not there good full five right
there so it took us like five five is
there right and and you get the idea
these keys are now distributed
everywhere and when you ask about it now
I'm going physically to the server
itself to ask about it but if I ask the
nodejs app it's going to give me these
values right so here's what I'm going to
do next right I'm going to do index.js
after I run all these which is I'm not
going to run it anymore right uh cuz I
already store these for an hour I'm
going to just go a loop and read right
going to create a function that reads
and exactly
similar uh
YY p and then just do a get right the
get is slightly different what we going
to do is that you don't need a value
right you don't need an expir date but
it's going to give you a function a
callback where it's actually two places
error and data right and then we just
print the data CU that's what we're
interested in assume there are no errors
here again this is a very simple app
here and then's just go ahead and read
so in this case you're talking to the
pool directly you're not talking to
individual machines so we know that the
keys were actually evenly distributed
between the servers because we ta
knitted into each servers and tested
that out right so now what we're going
to do is let's run and see node
index.js look at beautiful Bar Nine bar
two bar four bar three bar six Bar Seven
bar eight bar one bar five why do we get
the different values it's very easy
because we we're we're running
asynchronous job we have no idea yeah we
executed f one first right but Fu right
we we what do we did is like we looped
and sent all the 10 request at the same
time right
all this is what we did we looped and
all the 10 request but these are
asynchronous so Bar Nine F9 might get
give us a result before f8 right all of
these are just this is how no GS works
it's single threaded and it sends all
these request and just Loops through the
its main um the the main Loop the the
main thread Loop right and looks for the
result it depends on the server how fast
is going to respond right so is going to
send all these things and then hey the
server responds for this respond for
this for this we just do all this stuff
so the client here it really depends
what it does as well right so the client
really depends on this it took the hash
right of the f one determine that F1
should exist on This Server connect it
to the server asked for the value pull
that value and then return it so you
have no idea how fast these servers will
reply right and the number number of
connections to each server also really
matter right so that's basically uh it
for the demo guys and kind of explained
all this uh idea of MIM casd let's go
ahead and summarize this course all
right we did the demo let's summarize we
talked about memory management memory is
fragmented if we didn't do the slab
Pages concept then we're going to be
allocating values left and right right
and that as a result uh becomes
fragmentation and fragmentation is bad
because now you have all these beautiful
gaps of free space that we cannot use
unfortunately right because our items
might not necessarily fit these gaps
right so we need memory management lru
again uh very in unpopular opinion I I
would like for this to be an option to
be disabled so that I don't get locked
right and keep my application simple and
if someone want to build Anu why don't
they build it themselves right or just
have the client have the control I wish
they stayed simple and didn't implement
this just that's just my only this
criticism of the MIM casd they they
stayed simple they stick to their rules
this is to in my opinion I think it's an
Overkill right threads I love this
design yeah we can work with money
threads of course there is a limit for
there is another problem with the
threads design here is that let's assume
you have multiple threads all right and
each thread is a connection right let's
say about that right and and when we
looked at the data I think when we
looked at the stat we saw that there is
a fixed number of threads right and I
don't know if this if MIM casd
share connections on a given thread like
have multiple connection on thread I
don't know that maybe because otherwise
it's going to run out of threads right
so in this case what you you you can end
up with is a thread with a connection
that happen to have a very aggressive
client a client that sends a lot of d
data to the thre you know so in this
particular thing you create a bottleneck
and that
bottleneck really there is no solution
to it because you don't know if a
connection is going to be aggressive or
light waight right you can you can
change that complete model to a
centralized thread model where is a
center thread that takes the messages
these requests and these requests will
be distributed evenly right you can do
that but then the bottleneck is moved to
a single thread you lose either way
right there is no solution the best
solution that's when you when you when
you go into deep these things like it's
it's fascinating to me I absolutely love
it we talked about read and write talked
about locking about distribution cach
which is completely client side guys I
hope you enjoy this uh crash course Deep
dive level into MIM casd absolutely uh I
enjoyed researching this talk me a lot a
month to research this entire course uh
absolutely love it uh if you want to
support the channel become a member
there is a lot of uh member exclusive
content in this channel uh if you want
to support
otherwise there is the there's uh I have
a lot of UD me courses uh there's
discount coupons check it check them out
and that supports the channel I
appreciate you so much and thank you all
for your wonderful messages hope you
enjoy this course I'm going to see you
on the next one you guys stay awesome
goodbye